What is the best supplement available for cold or bacterial infection, drainage,
coughing, sinus issues with ear pain, but tested negative for flu COVID and strength?
First of all, I don't think anybody should be doing the COVID test.
Not accurate. It shouldn't be ready. It shouldn't be doing testing for COVID.
If you got this crud that's blown going around that I had a couple of weeks ago,
then what should you be taking? Why do the things that you're on for cancer
will be helpful for these things as well? But in general, if it's a bacterial infection,
you think of garlic, oregano oil,
astrayalis. Those are all good for bacterial infections. They're also good for viral infections.
Vitamin C with zinc, of course, you don't want vitamin C if you have cancer,
but taking short-term to deal with an infection. It's nothing wrong with that.
Your aloevia immune, which is polysaccharide, your other mushrooms,
are polysaccharides. They're good for immune stimulation.
Doing gargling with salt water can be good. Using the garlic oil, ear drops can be good.
Using holyo paths for lymph drainage. We have some from professional formulas that are really good.
The, what's it called, immune stem by herb farm. It's an echinacea,
straggolus, and stuff. Product is a liquid herbal that tastes pretty gross, but taking drops
under your tongue of that throughout the day is really good. There's a ton of different herbal
stimulants that are all safe to take for cancer. If you have an autoimmune disease,
those things, all those things that I just mentioned can actually flare an autoimmune disease,
but taking a very short term to deal with a sickness is typically okay to deal with. You just
don't want to take those immune stimulants long-term with an autoimmune disease because it can make
that worse. So people with cancer, and a serious autoimmune disease are in a catch-22
always, and that's more difficult if you're trying to kill the cancer. You're also trying not to have
this huge colitis flare or something, so it's balancing that out. Helmet comes in for sore throat,
a great success with onion, poultice, over your throat, bind with a scarf overnight. That's a good
choice. So there's a lot of things like that. There's we have some, we got a ton of stuff in our store.
I would just have to go down and walk through it to think of some of the products that you could take
for trying to build up your immune system, what you're dealing with this virus, or bacterial infection,
or whatever it is. One of the best things you guys have all of you in your house is a knife machine.
So run the cold and flu and the modia programs and run those programs. So currently we really have one
knife in our house. After I felt like I was recovered, even though I still kind of lost my voice,
from this stay a couple of weeks ago, my wife attempts to get things go to her lungs because she's
damaged her lungs when she was younger with the modia. So I brought the knife up and was running
on the modia blaster bacterial strap program for her because I think this thing going around has,
some people may have a bacterial component and several different viral components. So definitely
walk by the virus program on your right. That would be helpful.